FIFA fever has kicked off under watchful
eyes Larger than Life they Loom over
this River the debate is on who is the
greatest of them all Argentina fans were
the first to immortalize their Idol
Lionel Messi Neymar fans went bigger
only to be outdone by Ronaldo who stands
at 15 meters allowed towards football in
our Gene so there is healthy fan fights
happening challenges like this happening
here and in the World Cup also we have a
fan Park here and it will be very very
nice to watch a world cup from here in
the fun part Kerala state in Southern
India is all set for the World Cup fans
have dressed the streets in their
favorite Flags Billboards are
celebrating the biggest stars many local
tournaments are underway across the
state while Cricket is the most popular
sport in the country the beautiful game
dominates this region this world cup is
extra special people from Kerala are one
of the largest groups of people in Qatar
so even though India isn't playing they
feel like the world cup is close to home
FIFA has recognized kerala's special
connection with the hosts miniature Dows
are a popular artifact in the Middle
East a thousand of these have been
shipped to Qatar where they are part of
the tournament's official merchandise 26
26 of us worked on these women did the
Rope work
we worked on these day and night for two
months we only focus on making these
Taos
state government is organizing its own
competition it's asking enthusiasts to
score a million goals before the Opening
match officials say it's not only about
football we are connecting this message
of Andy drug activities campaign in
connection with so that people
especially students will get into it you
know they will more aware about this
problems so that is why we are
connecting this football and Andy drug
Campaign together
some fans will be traveling to Doha to
watch the matches even those who don't
follow the sports say they are thrilled
and proud of all the attention their
state is getting